the next talk I think is about the
Samplers distributions distribution
testing and we already have our first
challenge is distinguishing
distributions of speakers because we
have multi Source presenting this in the
program and
the actual speaker distribution seems to
be slightly different so
all right uh well there I have it's
Jacob mentioned
um good news and bad news but they won't
be presenting so you'll have to bear me
but I'm going to talk almost what what I
wanted to talk about today so it means
and I want to speak much today
[Laughter]
okay so um I'll be talking about a line
of work that Mata and I have been
pursuing with our collaborators sort of
chakraborty and printer Golia for past
few years
um and the problem setting that we have
been interested in a uniform sampling so
you are given a Boolean formula and you
would want to Output solutions that are
almost uniform
um what do I mean uh the simpler should
output every solution so that the
probability it outputs each of these
Solutions is one hour the total number
of solutions you allow a little bit of
slack of OnePlus Epsilon
okay so in edit instead of the set
problem where you are just impressive
one solid any arbitrary solution now we
would like to ensure that every solution
output almost uniformly
why one should be interested in this
problem uh it turns out to be a very
fundamental problem in theory as well as
a lot of applications in hardware and
software testing which is what motivated
our uh work in the first place
they spent almost a decade working on
this problem so when we started looking
at this problem it was a big gap between
scalabilities
um either you had techniques that could
scale to large instances or the
techniques that could provide strong
guarantees or effort was to be able to
build
so I spent quite a bit of time in
designing a sampler that has guarantees
so it uses this random exercise to
partition the solution space makes
logarithmically many calls and provides
the kind of guarantees one is interested
in and a lot of Advance has been uh due
to the availability of this set solver
that mate has been working for a long
time
and as one designed this sample a
question to ask is that well how do I
know that the same place uniform why so
well we have this template that we are
designed using is scalable but at the
same time there are instances that it is
not able to handle in such cases there
are other proposals and then those
purposes don't have the guarantees so a
natural question to ask is that well I
have a sampler it may not have
guarantees but I think it's going to do
well on the instance you are given to me
so the question is how do we know as
simple as uniform
um so the setting here is that we have a
reference sampler so you can imagine a
sampler that is really slow you have a
simpler that somebody claims to be
uniform and a formula
um what can we do to figure out whether
it's uniform one thing one can do is run
both the Samplers for a long time
you can eyeball the distributions
do some statistical checks like KL
Divergence chi-square test and so on
the problem is that these tests require
the number of samples which is the has
to be
at least as much as the number of
solutions the kind of formula where you
are interested in sampling the number of
solutions are usually very large
something of the order of two to the 50
2 to the power 60 and so on so that's
um
such an approach is not going to work
but if you try to draw conclusions based
on a small number of samples
that was done in a a work that uh
it was done in 2018 so here the author
said that
they took three Samplers they had
proposed a new sampler called quick
sampler they took the two existing
samples such tree and Uniden
the rent is based on a small number on
set of benchmarks is generated about
thousand samples you try to do these
tests on those thyroid samples
and they were not able to distinguish
between the three samplers but the
authors were also clear in pointing out
that one should take these results with
care because uh there are no guarantees
about how good these results are
is there a possibility of principal
approach
well we can ask
um in this case we can rely on the
progress in the field of distribution
testing
so what we are interested in is to
figure out if the distribution generated
by the sampler is close to uniform or
not one way to test uniformity can be
used to generate samples and stop the
moment you see the first policy so we
know that a uniform distribution should
take the longest amount of time to
generate a collision so any other
distribution you can run the two
Samplers and you stop the moment you see
a collision
how many runs you had to do so here is
one better one example so the
Distribution on the left side is uniform
distribution so it it's uniform on all
the solutions of the formula and in this
case it doesn't sample half of the
solutions and the on the other half of
the solutions it is uniform so if you
were to run these two samplers
then you would have to wait
at least until the square root of the
number of solutions so from 2 to the
power of 80 we are down to 2 to the
power 40.
while these two distributions are really
far from each other right in one case
you don't even sample half of the
solutions
are this is also the optimal if the only
thing you are allowed to do is to just
generate samples
there has been a lot of work in the
field of distribution testing where a
model that was proposed by sort of
chakraborty and kothas
which is the model of conditional
sampling so the model of conditional
sampling says that if you allow me uh to
condition on a distribution so more
formally we have a distribution on a set
s and you can allow me to specify a set
T and allow me to draw samples from the
um
from the distribution condition on T so
what do we mean by here the probability
is as solution is generated
h0 if Sigma doesn't belong to the T if
Sigma belongs to the T then it's as if
you had removed everything else outside
these so this is the sigma summing of
over all the solutions that I will see
so this is of course as powerful as the
normal sampling model because you can
just have S equals to T it turns out to
be much more powerful
is one way to
um
we can go back to the challenge instance
we have so on one end we have the
uniform sampler and this was a sampler
that was far from uniform so here's an
algorithm that's going to be able to
distinguish between these two samples
what we do here
a very simple one solution from the
reference sampler that is given to us we
sample another solution from the sampler
that we want to test
and now this is condition on these two
solutions so what's going to happen if
probability half
when we are drawing something from the
uniform sample
sampler we are going to draw one of
these points and if we just ask it to
condition on these two points it's
almost like you have a two-sided uh
one-sided point so if you just toss it
few times you'll be able to say that
well it's not uh you know uniform
and the simple algorithm actually works
for all cases so it is able to
distinguish simpler that are far from
uniform
so in 2019 we at that point we thought
that let's try to apply this algorithm
in the context of the problem that we
have here which is to be able to
distinguish uh CNF samplers
so the first challenge is how do we do
conditioning so you have a formula in
order to condition we want to say that
can you generate solutions that are in
this case Sigma 1 or Sigma 2. it's very
easy to write in a formula so you could
say that the formula I have a z and F
and X is either Sigma 1 or X is sigma 2.
the only issue is that if you look at
any Sam if you were to design a sampler
and if you have two solutions
of a given formula
the simplest thing is to just enumerate
all of the two solutions and just pick
one of them
so if you give a formula that has only
two solutions then most Samplers are
going to behave uniformly this is
bit of reminiscent to what this car
companies did once you start testing
them they behave very uniformly at
random because the number of solutions
they had to go over is just two so you
just enumerate the two to a conflict
so in some ways the Samplers don't
support conditional sampling
so in order to kind of work out
bridge between the theory that existed
and the problem that we had at hand
we wanted to be able to concept formulas
whose solution space is large
but then once you sample once you sample
a point in the solution space you could
just protect the sigma 1 or Sigma 2.
that there are many ways of doing so is
one way
um that we took uh forward so we had a
Boolean formula there are two solutions
Sigma on a sigma 2 we can concept
another formula so that if you project
the solutions on the original set of
variables is the sigma one or Sigma 2
at the same time the number of solutions
of the new formula are very large
but with the properties at the number of
solutions that are if you project them
on Sigma 1 is identical as the number of
solutions projected on Sigma 2. so if
you were to uniformly sample from free
head then you would also be uniformly
sampling when you project on Sigma 1 or
Sigma
project on the original set of variables
so in order to make Theory work it
requires an assumption in particular we
want to say that
the distribution
of the sampler that you obtain by
projecting on the original set of
variables would be as if
the sampler was sampling on the original
set of formula initially right so we
need some way of being able to say that
it is really doing conditional sampling
about the distribution so if
satisfy the Assumption because of course
a uniform sampler if you give a large
formula it's still going to continue to
uniformly sample if you project on the
original set of variables you are going
to get uniform samples for Sigma with a
sigma group but it may happen that there
is a sampler that is
um
not a uniform sampler but if you give
this kind of formula it becomes a
uniform sampler
so assuming that
um the sampler that we have is say that
it's a non-adverse wheel if it satisfies
our assumption in that case we are able
to
get a tester that we were looking for so
in particular the tester
uh is going to accept Samplers if they
are closed and it's going to reject with
probability at least 1 minus Delta if
they are far
and the number of samples that are
required are Depends only on the two
parameters Epsilon Theta they don't
depend on the number of solutions of the
formula which is crucial because earlier
it required it depended on the number of
solutions of the formula if you were to
do a test based on the collisions then
you would have to generate the number of
solutions that were square root of the
num the number of solutions are you
would have to generate the samples which
per square root of the number of
solutions of the formula
Okay so
this is where you know
the part about developing Theory ends
and now we wanted to see that well does
it really work in practice all of this
Theory can we take simpler that our
design and practice and be able to
distinguish them from the uniform
samples
remember I talked about they were when
the study that proposed quick sampler
tested between the three Samplers search
tree sampler quick sampler and unigen
and concluded that they were unable to
distinguish between these three samples
important thing here was that these two
Samplers did not have guarantees in
particular as just a very big guarantees
of uniformity quick sampler doesn't have
any guarantees while Unison has the
guarantees of almost
if you give these three Samplers as
input on about 50 benchmarks then we are
able to now see that
the tester which we call as barbaric is
about is able to reject
quick sampler on all the 50 instances
except Estes on some of them and accepts
Unison on all of them
in particular to accept we need a lot of
samples but you can reject very fast so
you have to repeat this test so in order
to accept your to repeat lots of times
but you can reject with the skill number
of samples
so a question that we started asking
ourselves that now that we have a tester
can we use this tester to design a good
sampler
suppose I give you a good tester can you
use this tester to design a good sampler
um is it possible to do so and if it's
possible here's a wish list that would
be nice to have they should be able to
design a simpler that should be as fast
as the sampler that don't have
guarantees
it should be able to pass the test
because we have access to the tester
and it should perform really well on the
Practical applications where one cares
about uniformity
so this is where
we relied on mate's expertise so mother
has been building this simpler sets of
the crypto mini set that has lots of
options about 150 or so
and
what
Mother Day raised to
tune load of these options in particular
you pick polarities and branch on
variables at random while still having
some scoring turning off pay and in
processing techniques you restarted
static intervals so all these different
and finally the sampler that we have is
this line of crypto mini search so you
take the crypto mini search and you set
these options
I'm sitting here and this is how you get
assembler
can we do block Solutions
do you block if you find find the
solution do you block it with the
clothes no no just in fact yeah why not
no no
which is of course very different from
how I spent about 10 years trying today
and samples which was to come up with
you know an algorithm prove its
correctness and then implement it here
is take this cdcl set solver and try to
come up with this uh options and hope it
works
the the way we uh this is the way came
up with the parameters was to use this
barbaric so you had this tester you have
benchmarks you run it every time it
rejects you see well something is not
working so you tune the parameters
and in contrast to
everything else we have been working on
we didn't even attempt to do any
theoretical analysis we just this is
going to be the sampler we are going to
have
okay let's see uh what does what can it
achieve so the first thing is can it do
better than the existing Samplers
without guarantees in terms of the
runtime performance I'm using the cactus
plot here as you can see that that
didn't seem like a very hard task it can
do way better than uh existing Samplers
when it comes in just in runtime
let's see how well it can do when we
give it the
uh for the tester so these were the
benchmarks that it didn't did not have
access to when we were uh when Mata was
designing a cmsl I'm going to call this
M plus CMS gen the Promenade
now we see that it's able to pass all
the
underlying tester except see Amazon on
all the 50 instances
okay so let's say uh if it works well on
uh applications one cares about
uh we have I I'm going to show you
results on two applications so one is in
the combinator testing so this is where
you have a system that has a lot of
configurations and you want to test it
the way to test a system with a lot of
configurations if you think about you
are flying a plane and there's a button
you really hope that someday somebody
push that button up and some days
somebody push that button down before
the plane took off so that's called One
Voice coverage that every Stitch was
toggled on and off you can also look for
two wise coverage where every pair of
switches were toggled and three wise
coverage four wise coverage so the
normal metric is T wise coverage so
where you are looking at every
combination of T features and see how
often they uh their combinations were
covered
um there has been a lot of work in Ty
designing what are combinatorial arrays
there is a lot of work on designing test
uh switch that try to achieve High
coverage and work using uniform Samplers
in the past
so we have about 110 benchmarks time out
of 32 hours we wanted to measure device
coverage that is two here
and we generate about thousand samples
so here is what how the results look
like
on x-axis we have the benchmarks on
y-axis we have the coverage so for every
Benchmark after thousand samples we want
to measure how much coverage we have
achieved
so it turns out
that if we use STS you get somewhere
close to 80 percent
use Quick sampler somewhere about 55 55
if you just use a set solver without
trying to randomize it's about 40
percent
um a sampler that head guarantees is
just not able to handle this Benchmark
so Uniden just can only handle six of
these benchmarks
and if you were to use cmsn you get 100
coverage on all such instances the first
time we did this results I was
absolutely convinced that we have made a
mistake so we re-ran all of those
standards we are indeed getting 100
coverage
let me talk about another application so
this is the application in uh coming
from
functional synthesis so where the task
is you are given a specification and you
want to synthesize a function that
satisfy the specification the set of Rd
approach right now is to
do the sampling on the specification
given
um as an input you use some machine
learning to come up with the candidate
functions and then you do counter
example gradual repair
so what we wanted to do is to just
replace the sampling step uh just plug
in different Samplers and see how well
the performance of the entire tool
turns out to be so here I'm saying the
results by plugging in you know CMS and
fixed sampler crypto mini set STS unit
N3
and I as you can see in case of Uniden
it's just not able to generate enough uh
samples within a time so it doesn't do
really well
and it turns out that quick sampler does
almost as well as just using a set
solver
the significant performance Improvement
if one were to use
if uh one were to use cmsn
so
let me try to summarize here's our
observation after uh past three years or
so
we are able to design a really efficient
sampler
that works well on real world
applications
and we have no idea why
it wasn't supposed to be this way
what can we do with this so some one of
the recent work was to say that well now
that
the tool is accepting on all except this
sampler on all such instances maybe you
make the tool to make it reject on some
instances so you can do some hardening
of the tool
and then we can again go and change the
parameters of the sampler so that it
still gets accepted but now we see that
the runtime performance degrades so
there seems to be interesting trade-off
between the runtime performance and the
quality of samples
one observation that we have is that if
the more frequent you do the restart
the worse the sampling quality seems to
be
so there there seems to be a lot of
opportunity for work to do it in
practice where you want to kind of tune
the proper tester so that the resulting
sampler is works well on the kind of
applications one cares about
and we are achieving this fifth spot in
terms of the runtime performance and the
quality of samples
the reason we wanted to talk about is to
ask Theory distance in the room to help
us understand what's going on
perhaps cdcl with randomizes all you
need in practice to generate to do
uniform sampling
um
or maybe in all such applications
it's not what uniformity that matters it
is able to generate this
samples According to some distribution
so if that's a distribution that really
matters to get good results and what is
that distribution
so what is the kind of distribution that
matters in cases such as the combinary
testing
and then can we say something about why
cmsn does really well
for theory and practice an interesting
line of work is to design a testing
methodology that doesn't have to rely on
this pesky observation of non-adversity
which which is what we needed in order
to at least have some meaningful uh
current statements
so with that I'll conclude I'll be happy
to take any questions
thank you this was very interesting it's
a great problem to have isn't it it
works much better than you expected
the magic line you had it looks like it
only had how many 10 12 that many
options yeah did you okay two questions
one did you use like an existing
algorithm tuner to get to that
second question is I think what people
do to explain this sort of thing is
feature importance analysis right you
could start fiddling with the features
like that's the simplest thing there are
people in this room who know much much
more than me about this have you done
anything like that
[Music]
if you're not talking about I'll try a
little bit
um I I personally don't believe in any
of these uh tuners like just don't
believe them at all I
yeah my personal experience I work with
the person who more or less invented
them and and did them and and it's very
famous for them and every time they gave
me something it didn't seem to make
sense to me and then yeah it's not very
robust I think that's the real issue
with them so an expert seems to be a
little bit more robust uh that's my
personal experience
um also it gives you something and then
you don't understand why it works which
uh I mean at least I understand why that
works because I I played with it and I
have an intuition of why it works
um yeah it's actually quite easy so you
can make mini sub do this it's uh it
just I think the polarity is randomly I
I take the I think most people would
guess this in five minutes right so you
take the polarities randomly they take
the variables randomly you do some
minimal simplifications like
subsumptions a substance resolution and
and uh accurate literal replacement and
that's it I think like
do restarts but fixed because the
problem is that if you don't do it fixed
then then then then what it will do is
that it it finds something that's kind
of hard and then and then goes down that
Branch you know and then it's like it's
fine it's really really hard and there
are solutions there but you know it you
don't give it enough time and it just
restarts and it finds the easy one and
actually that's exactly what we did for
the next paper that we did which is
already published it's called skull bar
break and it was just like how can I
beat this uh my own sampler because we
couldn't beat our own sampler which is
kind of I couldn't distinguish using bar
break or barely could distinguish and so
what we did is that we I came up with
this idea that on like if you set
variable one to two then then it's uh
then it's like two to the power of M
Solutions and under and if if a variable
one is false then there's like you have
to reverse a hash function to get 2 to
the power of n Solutions again and and I
mean you see what happens if if it had
randomly set that variable to one side
then it will it will immediately find a
solution and if not then unit set is the
wrong side then it will like go go and
it like takes a lot of time and then I'm
like oh okay I'm gonna restart and then
right then it goes down to the easy one
so you'll have tons of easy solutions to
make your hardens and so the way we
fixed it is that you just have fixed
restarts this is this is the trick that
we did and if you like the fixed result
is 10 000 100 000 conflicts or something
then it will it will go down the range
and never restart and eventually find a
solution
um yeah yeah you could you could but
then then it will be perfect but it will
be very slow
but second question will be actually
perfect like can you prove that it's
perfect
maybe one more question while the next
speaker sets up so
I think
so uh I believe it's a combination of
the parameters that
that gives you the
results right
so uh I mean
I'm sure see a crypto mini site has many
more parameters than this
so I mean how did you choose the one
that
nine or ten or twelve
okay
so let's uh thank you I guess kuldeep or
mate or both
[Applause]
no no distinguishing uh distribution
testing for the next stop which will be